fait j'avais rejoint le rassemblement
national fin 2015 en tout cas marine le
pen fin 2015
parce que j'avais trouvé qu'elle avait
dépoussiéré le front national d'antan et
avec marine le pen évidemment et on a on
a eu des élections enfin des scores aux
élections qui étaient de plus en plus
important donc quelque chose qui se
passait j'ai perdu mon coeur est en 2017
en 2017 il ya eu un coup d'arrêt et puis
j'ai assisté à une série de 2 de revenir
sur un certain nombre de choses dont
effectivement la question de de la
compatibilité ou de la compatibilité en
l'occurrence de l'islam avec la
république et elle semblait dans un
instant et donc gg que j'ai quitté leurs
astuces nationale là dessus c'est
toujours serbe l'affection de dire la
vérité en des adhérentes sur la vérité
c'est satan est ce que vous avez quitté
le rassemblement de salles parce que
vous sentiez aussi qui avait pas de
place pour vous que vous alliez pas
voilà vous étiez arrivé au maximum de ce
que vous pouvez faire et que marine le
pen ne comptez pas trop sur vous bien
voilà tout en toute franchise il ya eu
une divergence de ligne politique est
évidemment un moment quand vos
compétences et votre engagement pour
tout un tas de raisons ne semble pas
avoir été reconnus ben on prend le large
et que je prenais des risques en prenant
le large aussi un je me suis à l'époque
où je suis parti en novembre 2020 il n'y
avait pas reconquête il n'est pas eric
zemmour je suis parti je pensais même
plus revenir à la politique ben voilà
c'est la vie on pensait faire que de la
télé voilà c'est bah oui c'est vrai mais
ça et moi il me semblait que c'était
pour ça que
en fait vous avez été si dur vous avez
été séduit par eric zemmour vous êtes
dit je vais pour faire la politique
parce que je suis séduit par eric
zemmour bas parce que déjà je connais
eric zemmour depuis très très longtemps
sur le fond il n'y a pas l'épaisseur
d'une feuille de papier à cigarette
entre ce que ce qu'il pense et ce que je
pense et c'est vrai que j'ai attendu un
petit peu je n'ai pas rejoint tout de
suite hein et puis bon il m'a quand même
assez impressionné beaucoup de gens le
donner au départ ne dépassant pas les 3
% dont d'ailleurs marine le pen bon
voila il il a eu quand même une
progression qui a été spectaculaire il
s'est présenté présidentialiser aussi le
meeting de villepinte était quand même
quelque chose d'assez impressionnant et
je parle pas des meetings qui ont suivi
donc voilà donc à partir de là si vous
voulez je suis redescendu dans l'arène
aussi en prenant à risque parce que j'ai
quitté aussi là les plateaux télé où
j'aurais pu rester de manière portable
pour me relancer à nouveau dans l'arène
politique voilà dernière petite question
avant que je pose une à marine le pen
vous concernant aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez que marine le pen
est dans les sondages donnent au second
tour est ce que vous regrettez votre
choix
non parce que en fait c'est le même
scénario qui se rejoue depuis depuis
déjà des années c'est à dire que
le rassemblement national de manière
générale on le donne en tête à chaque
fois dans les sondages et puis aller au
deuxième tour des visas la fin oui mais
déjà au premier tour marine le pen était
cassé croire en dessous de certains
arrêts prévus quand on lit les sondages
des dernières élections territoriales
quels que soient les scénarios nous d&o
leur assemblée nationale allait récolter
au moins trois régions et plusieurs
départements en résultat des courses il
ya eu zéro plus zéro alors je sais que
marine le pen à l'époque a engueulé ses
électeurs parce que ceux ci se sont pas
déplacés donc voilà il ya quand même je
je je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre du systémique de lors du déjà-vu
qui fait qu'à chaque fois on nous
annonce le rassemblement national et
marine le pen en tête de tous et puis en
fait ça fait pschitt quoi jean meyer
pour vous eric zemmour va terminer
devant marine le pen 1er tour écoutez
moi je suis pas devin mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je constate que
sur le terrain pour parcourir la france
et faire campagne dans divers meetings
les meetings sont pleins on a des
centaines de personnes voire des
milliers quand c'est eric zemmour qui
attendent qu'ils ne peuvent pas entrer
dans les salles on a un parti qui a été
créé il ya trois mois il ya déjà six
fois plus d'adhérents que le
rassemblement national donc je dis sur
le terrain il se passe quelque chose
c'est dire qu'en fait si des objets
estimés ou eric zemmour est partout
c'est que dans les sondages c'est qu'il
est sous-estimée dans les sondages je
pense qu'il est sous-estimée dans les
sondages vous savez autres autres et
autres éléments alors je suis en mars
2000 en main même à leurs yeux alors
mars 2002 jean marie le pen était donné
à 8 pour le jeu seul je sais que celle
de sa pré u oui mais a laissé tomber
lors de l'union non mais j'en mais
s'ajuste petit truc si je vous aime
beaucoup donc vous vous basez sur les
sondages quand vous dites on le donnait
à 3% là il est à
12-13 là mais vous dites les sondages
sont pas bon quand
non non pas du tout j'ai dit je dis je
dis juste que vous savez les sondages
doivent être corroborées avec le terrain
or ce qu'on constate sur le terrain on
le pourra pour eric zemmour est conquis
on le constate pour aucun de la croatie
c'est aussi simple que ça donc ça
interroge à tout le moins marine le pen
il vous manque jamais ça non
non non parce que nous avions
incontestablement
enregistré un certain nombre de
divergences récurrentes mais c'est pas
moi qui ai changé d'avis 1 c'est lui
parce que moi en 2017 sur l'islam je dis
exactement ce que je dis aujourd'hui 1
voilà je le dis je les dis sur le
plateau de tf1 je les dis dans mes débat
je les dis et ça n'avait pas l'air de
déranger gens à l'époque bon ça le
dérange est d'ailleurs tellement pas
qu'il a dit sur al jazeera pour dire la
même chose que moi donc je compte j'en
ai conçu l'idée qu'on pensait la même
chose dont il a changé d'avis il a le
droit d'ailleurs assuré dire je lui en
veux pas d'avoir changé d'avis mais
c'est pas la peine d'enrobé comme ça des
départs avec des argumentations qui sont
fantaisistes moi j'aimerais qu'on
discute d'ailleurs de ces divergences
bien sûr parce que moi j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu gens dire des choses quand même
extrêmement brutal alors justement là
marion c'est incroyable de vous entendre
dire sur l'islam j'ai entendu gens mais
c'est à dire des choses brutales c'est
quelque chose qu'on aurait jamais cru
entendre